ladies and gentlemen welcome to the tim
dillon show
uh a little squeeze here starting uh a
little late
because uh someone was late
someone was a little late
do you have any defense for your
tardiness the traffic was
heavy i tried to be on time the traffic
it's always something the traffic
well you said you were going to record
it three and then you moved it
i was doing a thing with my wife i was
that a thing
you know i mean i had to run from it and
then
you had to run from the thing you were
doing yeah we
did your job there was a friend in
austin who was in town and you had to
run
from the friend to your job well you
said we were gonna record it four then
you moved it to three
so so i moved it your job was moved
and you had to leave why don't you go
back to the friend
i think you should go back to your
friend go back call your friend and say
go back to your friend let's just do the
show let's you go back to your friend i
think it's better for you to go back to
your friend
seriously i'm dead's here please go back
to your friend
who's going to produce the show i'll
figure it out
i'll figure it out
it's insane um
ladies and gentlemen welcome to the tim
dillon show uh
beautiful day in austin texas a mass
shooting downtown uh and in true austin
fashion
no one was killed 13 people injured no
one was killed this city cannot even do
that right amazing
have you learned your lesson okay
moving on big announcement
to be made on the show
and i don't usually say that because we
don't usually have big announcements we
have them
rarely um and this announcement i
believe will be shocking
it will be stunning and i'm not a shock
value comedian that's not what we do
um but this will be genuinely
uh paradigm shifting it will
it will move people genuinely i believe
and because it is so unexpected
there's no there's there is never a hint
you you know a lot of the things that
happen here there's some foreshadowing
elements
but not this this is uh out of the blue
as they say it's coming out of the blue
it is completely
uh utterly uh without um
any preconceived
this this is just happening
organically it it just
it's really it's shaken
uh me to my core
the announcement i'm about to make
because i'm
i i understand how big of a deal it's
going to be to people
and how much it's going to throw them
throw them off
and i and i want to do it with care and
i want to prepare them uh and i want to
take
the utmost care and caution with an
announcement of this gravity
because this is this is there's gravity
here this is real it's hard to even say
it's hard to vocalize it's hard to get
out of my mouth
it's hard to
bend
why are you laughing i don't why are you
laughing
what's funny about this i don't know i
don't know
five months ago ben's wife
told us she was having an affair with
joe rogan
it was uncomfortable we respect and love
joe
he's incredibly generous nobody has done
more for comics than joe
no one but even
even that being the case it was still
tough to hear
that ben's fiance his wife
was having sex with joe who had been so
good to both of us it put
us in a very difficult position his wife
then
informed us that she was going to keep
the affair going
and in order to do that we needed to
move
to austin texas so she could continue to
have sex
with joe ben being a good husband
dutifully agreed and he came to me and
he said
katie wants to keep having sex with joe
rogan
do you think we should move to austin to
make it easier for her
so that she doesn't have to keep flying
and i agreed i said yes
so ben's wife has been
carrying on an affair with joe
even the morning of their nuptials
they got married but in in the morning
of that day
she was having sexual congress with joe
rogan
and and she told ben that at the wedding
in front of a few of us she had a few
drinks
and she said i just want you to know i
[ __ ] joe this morning
now something happened
there was a disagreement
i don't know what
we're not privy to that information and
i don't want to speculate
but ben's wife has ceased
her affair with joe she has stopped
she is no longer having an affair with
joe
she's back to sleeping with ben
now it is awkward
living in austin texas so the
announcement
is as follows because of ben's wife and
only ben's wife
it is time to leave austin texas the tim
dillon show
will be leaving austin texas
um in all seriousness because
what i was just saying was a joke i hope
for your sake it is a joke right i think
so yeah
in all seriousness we came down here
because the quarantine had warped
everybody's minds
i had moved from l.a to palm springs i
spent a lot of time in the desert alone
in 120 degree weather um
and and then i went on the road a lot
too and i did a lot of stand up
did comedy during the craziest uh period
in the history of this country maybe to
do comedy
during a pandemic with the most
contentious presidential election
i did comedy the night donald trump was
put into the hospital with kovid
i mean this was [ __ ] wild those shows
were
wild doing them and we did them we did
them to go out and to make money
to see fans to to do it as carefully as
we could to keep ourselves
mentally healthy and keep people
mentally healthy
and keep people working that worked at
comedy clubs
and we did them distance see we did them
outdoors and we did them
and and then joe who we love and respect
said i'm moving to texas and it it
it came at a time when l.a was
particularly bleak
and nothing was open and
i'd never loved austin i i had gone here
and i've done south by southwest i've
done the moon tower
comedy festival but austin to me always
felt like brooklyn it was
fun but it was yeah a lot of hipsters
and the food was good a little
one note it's barbecue we get it great
mexican food as well
um but it was a college town it was a
small
city this was not a uh world-class city
it just was not and i hadn't been here
for a while and i
i i didn't know and and i moved here
because i felt like i needed something
new
and that something new would be good and
yes the taxes are better
and yes there are uh benefits to not
being in la and yes
la has a host of problems but i moved
here because
first and foremost i said something new
will be
good um
i was wrong i was wrong
um the city of austin texas
is a city in the realm of the
of the artistic or whatever for people
who have
left new york or l.a or never had the
guts to go
to new york or l.a it's for people who's
they've never figured out a way to make
their art or whatever commercially
viable
and they should have a city those people
should have a place to get drunk at 2
a.m
to get high to eat brisket they should
have it it's their culture
do not force them to be productive
members
of society uh it shouldn't happen
that's the culture of austin if the
slacker the near duel
always has been always will be a few uh
exceptions
mike judge richard link letter but the
vast majority of austin
quite proudly is uh
a culture of not making it not doing it
for whatever reason um so when joe wants
to create a comedy hub here god bless
him
but he's fighting against a current and
cultures
matter and this culture has been around
for a very long time
and i have no interest in colonizing a
city and making people
uh making it into a great comedy city i
don't care um
the tech people are moving here they'll
have 3d printed brisket
uh they'll they'll have uh you know the
house values that go up
i bought a home here i'll rent it or
i'll keep it and
i'm not worried about that i think it's
a great real estate move i'm speaking
solely
about comedy and me and this show
it is not the move um
austin has many of the problems of los
angeles a lot of the homeless people
there was a mass shooting last night 13
people got injured not shot not killed
of course not
even the mass shooters in austin
can't get it done
and the cops didn't even find the guy
he's running around here
on the loose he's on the loose
we got a mass shooter on the loose it
could be any one of our friends
we should call the tip line and just
read off my instagram the people i'm
following
but we love joe we respect him when joe
has a club i'll come back here and work
at that club and be excited to do so but
i
i just could not get in a groove with
this city i tried
not really um but i i gave it some
effort
i gave it a uh you know i've been i've
been downtown four or five times
that's enough that's enough the first
time i went down there homeless people
were throwing bottles at us as we walked
out of the creek in the cave
people are being killed at night the
homeless are just going up and murdering
comedians and i don't even know am i
against that
i i i'm i'm put in this weird position
of of of having to care about a city
that i've never
cared about and i i can in good
conscience
do that i only want to be funny i
only want to really affect people with
what we do
i don't give a [ __ ] about hostage i love
texas
i love the areas around austin are
beautiful i like dallas and houston and
fort worth and
the audiences are great but i don't care
what happens to the comedy community of
austin texas
i don't care it has been forever
a community of sloth-like people
truly slugs slugs
and they should have it
it should be for them
joe rogan can walk around here and ask
people be like hey why don't you write
more
shouldn't you work out it's not gonna
work
because they're losers
to the bone these people are losers to
the [ __ ] bone
the stench of human failure in this city
is so that you cannot breathe you cannot
inhale oxygen because the stench
of human failure infects
all of the air it is a grotesquery here
they do not know how to run a city the
food
is [ __ ] there's two places that make
good barbecue and they're not terry
blacks
it's franklin in the barbecue and it's
nine hours
line to a blue-haired
tattooed lesbian can give you an
attitude
when you say can i add a sandwich to
that
people come here to get married like
this fool
because it's cheap and you can get
married in some raft
you could float down a dirty river and
get
down syndrome drunk and take photos
to put on your facebook
he did have a beautiful wedding but the
point is this my point still stands
this is the bachelorette capital of the
south
it's drunk pig women
and men that have an itchy trigger
finger just trying to shoot people
dancing around sixth street drunk
these people are out of their [ __ ]
minds
it's a [ __ ] rodeo of fat [ __ ] and
school shooters
everybody eating at the trough it has
nothing to do with music can we
say that now can you hear it loud and
clear
this town has nothing to do
with music there are
heroin addicts that occasionally
do melodious things on the street
while they're after they take a [ __ ] in
the street
they play i don't know you are my
sunshine
or something you my uh you make me happy
when skies are gray
[Music]
it's nothing it's less than nothing
here there is no seafood there is no
fish
there is one sushi restaurant that joe
rogan mentioned and now you can't get in
until 2027.
sandra bullock and matthew mcconaughey i
don't give a [ __ ]
i don't care that a couple of white
demon celebrities live here show you
white mouth
what's funny about that is that i've
been very critical of the critical race
theory and yet i find in times
it is important to have in the pocket
this is what it is i tried
i played pickleball with a few
psychopaths
we met a few tech people we met a few
people
who when you looked in their eyes you
realized
that uh uh trouble was a bruin
we met some of the masters of the
universe not the bankers
some of the uh you know silicon valley
cultists
who are colonizing the area who are here
because of no state income tax and their
love of baked beans
some of the libertarian wing of the tech
movement
some lovely people maybe not too bad
don't hate any of them i like being
afraid for my life
during the afternoon i like that
i don't i don't think facial expressions
are necessary
i like people
that keep you on your toes but it's
time to go
and i don't want to discourage anyone
else from moving here it may
be your destiny to come here many of you
will be happier
floating down a route which by the way i
tried to go to the swimming hole
you have to make a reservation for the
swimming hole
you can't even jump in the [ __ ] lake
without a reservation or the creek or
the crick whatever you call it i've had
about enough
i've had about enough
i can't work on caitlyn jenner's
campaign long distance i have to be
there
i gave it four months and i'm not going
anywhere immediately this summer i'm
touring and then in the fall i start to
look and
who knows where we end up next maybe we
end up in dorado
puerto rico with the pauls and peter
schiff
here's to hoping but it's time
to go there was a mass shooting last
night 13 people were injured outside
the vulcan gas company the venue of the
moment
it's time to go i love joe joe's been
more generous to comics
he's done so much for us we don't
deserve it he deserves happiness go and
be
happy and if he opens a club i will come
down here and work it and be thrilled to
do so
but right now it is time to go
this has been a fun experiment uh the
quarantine has been very interesting
i've made and lost friends i've made bad
decisions i've made good decisions
we've all done wild things uh
we've put ourselves into situations we
never thought we'd be in
and we've taken ourselves out of
situations uh we never thought we would
get out of
our minds melted we uh you know kind of
went through the looking glass it was an
acid trip without having to take the
acid and it was not a good one it was a
bad one it was good for us
it was good for certain people you know
but the reality is that is over now and
for some people it'll never be over
they'll keep the masks
whatever let them let them do it fine
it's fine
but it is now time to leave and and you
know bait it's gonna be a little tough
for ben ben will fly and do the show
every week
and you'll have to really kind of talk
to your wife
because it's going to be difficult but
we've suggested gaslighting her into
making her believe she
made us move here yeah that's an f
that's an option
you haven't told her yet no i i i will
before we put this out
you have not told her i have not told
her anything no not yet
i told you you're renting your house out
that you bought but that's it
did she ask why she just i just said
that you were gonna make like
money on the income from the thing and
be cash positive did she say where would
he live
i said he was just thinking about
extending his rental here so you lied
yeah so you made it you made something
up
so far we're lying we're in the lying
stage
what does she want to do go downtown to
get a bottle thrown at her head
is that what she wants to do does she
want to go play the accordion downtown
and get raped with a
bottle a glass bottle to her neck
it's chaos down there it's utter hell
and chaos
it's chaos down there okay it's sahara
yeah
la's big enough austin's not that big
also like seven square blocks and two of
them are hell
two of them are fallujah it's crazy
so what so to to do what so you can eat
it
[ __ ] you know miss vicky's brisket
house who gives a [ __ ]
can we get the [ __ ] out of here please
can we get the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] were we thinking can we
get the [ __ ] out of here please do i
want pickles and onions with it
no give me a ticket i'm leaving i'm
leaving
get the tattoo off your neck white demon
[Music]
i've had enough of a white homeless kids
i'm out we're out of here
burn it to the ground sorry
the truth hurts as lizzo has said
there's parts of it that are nice
there's parts of it that are beautiful
not the city
the outskirts and those will be the
parts that get nice it's the marin
county thing here
they let san francisco go to [ __ ] and
the surrounding area
went skyrocketing that's what's gonna
happen here that's what i believe
but i believe comedically artistically
for me for you for the show
for the future of what we have to do
this city
has tested me
it really has i i i don't get it
i don't get the charm here i don't get
what everybody else gets
i don't get what's fun about five fat
drunk [ __ ] from nashville
on sixth street drunk and falling down
shoving and then getting in a tub of
macaroni and cheese
i don't get it look at the ban you wanna
hear
the band
not good we've covered it all we did the
text [ __ ]
we had lunch with a few people we we did
a few shows they were decent they were
fine
it's time to get out i don't even want
to do moon towers she didn't ask me to
do i don't want to do any of it
south by i went out of this town for a
long time for a goddamn long time here
i went out of this town and i may rent
the house may just keep it it's fine
it's a beautiful little thing to have
it's not that expensive it's not i
didn't go nuts and buy a crazy thing
so it's all gonna work out but i mean we
do have to tell
you to tell your wife and then i'll have
to give you guys a bunch of money which
i have no problem doing
but you know it's it's unfortunate well
what do you feel about this be very
honest here because you got excited to
come back to texas
and it started worrying me because you
and your wife started going to see
fiddle players
and you're like oh you should come see
the fiddle player with us and i got very
nervous because i said
this is everything you left to not be
somebody some [ __ ] some guy sitting
in a field listening to a fiddle player
i don't like uh the golf courses here i
don't like the food well that's nice
you don't like the golf not at all what
is the problem with it
i don't like link style courses right i
like uh i like a nicholas designed
course in l.a somewhere right
shut up but that's it's important
it's important that there are things you
also don't like the food's trash
it's not good it's trash the people
the people it's like if every witch
from a disney movie got fat
it's like what happens to maleficent if
she starts a podcast
and eats 14 sandwiches a day
and dyes her hair blue she lives in
austin
thought people should at least be
talented headlight on their feet
jackie gleason yours truly not these
lumbering soulless [ __ ]
vessels just barking at people
that's ableist
[Music]
they gotta go and i wish everyone the
best here
i do i do i wish everyone the bad i
cannot stress that enough
because as somebody who's invested in
austin real estate it is a great place
to live
and that's what people forget is that it
is a great city
it's a great american city and i have a
lot of hope
for the future of austin and i i love it
here
and to leave kills me because the food
is great
as we've talked about and the people are
great
and i like it you know what i mean it's
not that bad yeah no
not at all so if you're thinking of
coming here
and renting or buying it's the place
it's the move
because what i like about it is you have
a good balance of nature
and then also a thriving vibrant
metropolis
when you go to austin there's always
something to do
get followed by a homeless guy on the
way to go get a taco from a
dodge durango that's parked because
everybody eats food here out of a truck
you could do that you could catch a
stray bullet on sixth street
while walking back to your uber that
doesn't show up and if it does we'll
kidnap you
there's a lot of benefits to this city
okay so i don't want to scare anyone
away
from it i have to be but this is a big
announcement
it's a big announcement it's a big deal
the fact that we're moving to dorado
with peter chef in the polls
no we're not we're not going to dorado
we're we're going and we're staying the
next place we go which is
california we're staying we're going to
los angeles we're staying we're going to
stick it out it is what it is
i mean at the end of the day we really
tried here i tried
people said it was gonna last four
months and it lasted about four months
and
i'm not leaving immediately i'm on tour
i'm on the road and i've got things to
do
okay irs i'm here this year
i'm here this year
but next year you know and
the fall you know it's like it's tough
and i know that
you and your wife are happy here because
the dogs have a yard they're gonna have
a yard in los angeles too
the dogs are disgusting i mean one of
them has
three legs and none of it matters so
it's all good i i know it's gonna be a
tough discussion to have are you nervous
about it
no no katie's uh ride or die
i understand that yeah yeah and she was
riding joe
is there a way we need to gaslight her
into thinking that she made us move here
because she has a crush on joe
but we need we need to leave there's
there's nothing else to be said about it
i'm not performing at your bachelorette
party
no i'm not doing that no i don't care
about your wedding
ugh it's a college town
like without that many college kids yeah
you know i mean i just i just have to go
sorry i apologize
you know at the end of the day i wish
nothing but the best
for the people that live here i hope
that it's only a flesh wound that's what
i'll say
but it's not for me i must go now
i must go back to an underprivileged
area
called beverly hills
where people are real and they struggle
you understand where people have real
jobs
like i'm a sex slave slash
assassin pa on blackish
real jobs real people real america
i'm not excited to go back to california
there's a whole host of issues there
which caitlyn jenner will hopefully cure
but it's time to go it's time to leave
austin texas the faces of the people
the faces of the people the insects that
crawl
god bless people trying to make this
into something
god i mean picture
picture someone you know who's been a
disaster their entire life drunk drug
addict in and out of rehab
thief just the worst person
maybe not a horrible soul but just steps
on rakes their entire life
can't seem to get it going and then
imagine the most the winner the most
productive person you know
the most productive human being you've
ever met
wins every game gets the hot check
gets the money is a nice person
genuinely deserves it is generous
that person that you know the winner
the alpha the winner now
is bringing the fat drug addict thief
out and going
this is the goal
this is the goal this and you're going
but that's they're a fat
drug addict thief i'm pretty sure like
looks up things on the dark web and the
winner goes no
no no no no no they're good
they're it's a much better they're a
much better quality of person
and you go i don't think so and the
person is screaming as the winner goes
no no this person is good the person is
screaming
no i'm a fat mess i like it
i don't like good i hate good i never
want to be
good
food falls down on the floor starts
pissing themselves
heroin shooting heroin their fat arm
like
[Laughter]
and then the winner is like that's
pretty cool
and you go what no that's pretty cool
that's a pretty cool
[Music]
we wish everyone the best we wish
everyone the best here
and i'm i'm just hoping
that it's been it's been it's made me
realize a lot of things living here
and uh culture really matters the
culture of a city matters miami's a
party
never turn miami in anything that's not
a party how dare you new orleans is also
a fun party why ever turn that in
new york is a hectic uh race to nothing
leave it be that let it be this hectic
frenetic
pace to eventual you know death but
they like that it's necessary it
sharpens people it molds them into
something
10 of them the rest of them who cares
but
l.a is is a den of sociopaths
narcissists
people that it's fake on a level it's so
fake it's real
you're just talking to human volcanoes
as they stuff avocado toast
down their genetically engineered
throats into their plastic bodies
and then they go vomited up it's
important
just like new york is important just
like miami is important
just like austin being the den of
failures is important
being a place for losers a place for
those fat bachelorettes
to feel like they're going to the big
city
big mama's in the city now
she's got her brisket and she's gonna
take a shot of so-called lime
and then they're gonna play her song
which is up by cardi b
and she's just gonna be like
and her brain her useless brain is just
gonna bounce around in her head
and she's gonna go and just this mass of
flesh
this total waste of resources just
gyrating like a pig in the middle of the
street
while all her friends look at her and i
can't believe she's getting married
this thing is getting mad and she's
going to jar right in the street
because this is her three days to get
really [ __ ] up before she has to go
back to checking elderly people in for
the hysterectomies
and she's just like
and then some mass shooter is going to
come out
and he's going to see this person going
and the smash shooter is going to look
at her and go you know
this mass shooter is going to say i'm
sorry joe rogan
i'm sorry comedy
i've got a bit too and he's gonna fire
wildly into the crowd
like a monster like a monster not good
not condoning this and he's gonna hit
this fatty
and it will barely stop her she'll just
she'll feel it and she'll still
she'll get a little up and it's up and
it's up
and then her friends have to go you've
been shot
and then they put her on the gurney
[Music]
and then they bring her to the hospital
and then they extract this piece of
metal
out of her [ __ ] pulled pork filled
flesh they extract this uh bullet from
her
and she's like and then her fiancee
calls her goes
i love you are you okay and she goes
i am okay i love you
and then she's got a story for the rest
of her life she's got a story
for the rest of her life and then she
goes on a little bit of workman's comp a
little disability can't go back to work
and and and then she goes back in a few
years
to that place in austin she goes back
there
to see where a guy shot her in the leg
while she was gyrating to a cardi b's
up which they won't play anymore this
will be years later she'll have two fat
jalapeno popper sized children
and her husband who tries to drink
himself into a grave every night and
sometimes damn near succeeds
and they'll get out of whatever uber or
which vehicle austin permits at that
time and they'll get out and she'll go
that's where mommy got
shot and they'll take a photo where she
got
shot they'll take a photo with that
bullet ripped through her [ __ ] flash
and she'll make it her profile picture
and she'll have some quote
she'll have some quote about that how
life is about appreciating the little
things
and she won't be a her quote because
she's [ __ ] [ __ ]
so she'll take it off some lifetime
movie of the week or some magnets she
saw at a friend's home
where she was getting juiced before her
kids got home from school
and she'll put that quote up and
there'll be a photo of where mommy got
shot on sixth street and that
is all this [ __ ] city
will ever be burned
uh barry wise ladies and gentlemen
everybody is getting into liquid ivs
it's a fact
first thing in the morning before
workout when you feel run down daily
hydration maintenance
hangover cures etc what do you love most
about it it's great
tasting functional products makes you
feel great i'm telling you they've
donated over 10 million sticks to people
around the world
which hydration flavors or products do
you like the most
i personally like the passion fruit some
people like the guava
the watermelon apple pie or strawberry
they also have lemon lime
acai berry i'm telling you right now
liquid iv can provide two to three times
more hydration than water
it contains five essential vitamins more
vitamin c than an orange and as much
potassium as a banana
we just came through a pandemic you know
you got to help your immune system
keep everything active keep everything
sharp healthier than sugary sports
drinks no artificial flavors or
preservatives
less sugar than an apple made with clean
ingredients non-gmo vegan free of gluten
dairy and soy
what makes liquid iv so effective
cellular transport technology
the optimal ratio of glucose sodium and
potassium delivers water
and nutrients into the bloodstream it's
the perfect balance to help you hydrate
more quickly
and effectively than just water alone
it's great energy i do this before i get
on stage i have so much energy on stage
people say how do you do it
is it cocaine it isn't it's liquid iv
one stick of liquid iv in a 16 ounce
thing of water can give you as much
hydration as two to three bottles of
plain water
liquid iv is on a mission to change the
world they're donating 4 million
servings in response to covet 19.
products are being donated to hospitals
first responders food banks veterans and
active military
liquid iv has donated over 10 million
servings globally
so if you love the tim dillon show and
you want to support it and you need more
energy
you want to feel better healthier more
hydrated
grab your liquid iv in bulk nationwide
at costco or
you can get 25 off when you go to
liquidive.com
and use promo code tim at checkout
that's liquidive.com
use promo code t-i-m at checkout
l-i-q-u-i-d-i-v
dot com if you are sitting at home going
am i spending too much on my
auto insurance home insurance and you
want quotes real time quotes
comparing the same coverage you have now
with other cheaper options
i'm telling you right now gabby is the
move
gabby is the way to get better insurance
i know what i've done it
it's the only true comparison platform
with fast verifiable quotes
not ballpark guesses use your current
policy to find a better policy
okay i did this when i bought my car i
went on gabby i said
here's the policy that i have i found a
cheaper policy with the same coverage
average savings are 900 a year which is
crazy gabby customers they'll never sell
your info
so no annoying spam or robocalls if you
want to start getting your finances in
order
you should look at what you are spending
on auto insurance
most people do not even know what
they're spending they don't even look
because it's very hard to get accurate
comparisons but gabby does it
i mean 961 dollars per year on average
and they'll never
ever be the reason you're getting
annoyed during the day
put your policy to the test like i did
get a better insurance with gabby it's
totally free to check
and there's no obligation go to
gabby.com tim dillon that's g-a-b-i
dot com slash t-i-m-d-i-l-l-o-n
tim dillon gabby.com tim dillon
see if you can save money on your auto
and home insurance
right now ladies and gentlemen welcome
to the tim dillon show exclusive people
were angry with me last week from my
one-sided
uh segment on israel and palestine with
of course journalist abby martin
uh who took a decidedly anti-israel view
as is her right
um and so we wanted to find somebody who
would come on and present the other side
um and we have barry weiss who has a uh
among other things a very good sense of
humor and uh
she is here with us to present
um i would imagine probably quite a
different view
from what abby has presented we're here
from the bitcoin conference
in miami barry by the way thank you for
coming on and having a good sense of
humor we do give you a hard time
uh every now and then but we do
appreciate that you're willing to come
on the show we
we we think that's a good thing well the
mossad gave me a special dispensation to
be here they're
they're big fans big big fans wow yeah
i'm sure
i'm i'm sure they are so my my first
question for you would be what are we
what are we getting wrong right like the
the narrative that is um that that is
coming out
that most people are seeing is that you
have uh
two groups um that are not matched uh
in any real way not in military uh might
not in economic power um uh
not in any type of power you have israel
which is it which is a strong
military um and you have
uh palestine which is i believe
two million or so people living in a in
a small area that don't really have
uh the military capable of
of having what seems to it doesn't look
like a fair fight right it seems like
you have one side now all these words
are being thrown out like apartheid and
genocide and things like that
what is mainstream narratives getting
wrong because it does seem this less
conflict
the mainstream narrative seems to have
switched a little bit where people are
now seemingly more sympathetic to what's
going on
in uh palestine and the way i've always
looked at it seems like a very untenable
unsustainable situation right it seems
like that
i'm sure that the pro-israel people
recognize that people that uh
don't agree with things israel has done
recognized that um
but what are people getting wrong about
this when we see
uh you know the the the bombing of
palestine when we see
um uh children being harmed and we uh
see that
palestinians are unable to access
medical supplies or
clean water or things like that what
about that or are we not
kind of what are we missing
so i think two things one is history and
the second
is really the aperture of the lens that
you're using to look at the conflict
with
so let's start with the second thing
which is if you're looking at the
israeli-palestinian conflict like this
you're going to see exactly to some
extent him what you just described
you're going to see
israel as the goliath that has the
military power etc
and you're going to see palestinians as
having the the less strong hand
but if you widen out and zoom out with
your lens
what you're going to see is an entire
region
filled with something like 22 arab and
muslim nations
and a jewish state the only jewish state
in the world
that is smaller than than new jersey
that state surrounded on all sides
the abraham accords aside and we can get
into that by people that
don't seek its borders to be shifted
but that fundamentally seek its
destruction i think the thing that
people fundamentally get wrong
is that they think that this is a
conflict fundamentally about borders
it is not a conflict about borders it is
a conflict about whether or not
israel has a right to exist it is a
conflict
about zionism and anti-zionism it's a
about whether jews like every other
people has a right to self-determination
in this case in their native land or
whether or not they don't
that is what the conflict is about
whether or not jews can have any
presence
in the region of the middle east at all
that's what this conflict is about and
so to go back kind of to
you know to to go back and watch the
abbey martin clip and of course i you
know defend her sacred right to
say that 911 was an inside job and
everything else that she says but
well there's a lot about 911 we don't
know whether it's an inside job or not i
mean it's not there's a lot we don't
know
we covered for saudi arabia for years we
really
then we said we released a 911
commission report the people on the 911
commission reports that it was set up to
fail
i mean these are direct quotes so i mean
it's not i understand that
no one's saying jews did 9 11 or
whatever i know some people are
well some people are some people are but
there's a lot we don't know there's a
lot we weren't dealt with honestly about
911 we went and attacked iraq
you know so okay well okay that was a
throwaway line
i understand what you mean like yeah
what i meant to say is that
you know everyone has the right to their
own positions but
i'm not going to sit here and listen
while people
spew lies and there's a giant lie that's
being told right now about israel and it
has
incredible power right now especially on
the far left
and that lie goes like this the jews
are white people they are
ethnocolonialist nationalists
who dropped into a foreign exotic land
with which they have no connection and
since 1948 when they plopped into this
land
they have systematically taken that land
from the indigenous brown population of
palestinians
and indeed more than that they're
bloodthirsty
they're warmongers and they won't stop
until they've
you know immiserated the people around
them and the problem with this is that
absolutely none of it is true it is a
fantasy projection
created by people with small brains who
have an attention span the length of a
tick tock video
you know the jews aren't let's start
with the jews aren't white
the jews are from the middle east the
jews
go back to the middle east for three
thousand years
that is the reality the jewish people
precedes the modern conceptions that we
have of
race and of religion okay they were a
tribe they were the
judeans they were the judaized living in
judea
and the jewish presence in what we now
call the land of israel or the palestine
that goes back all the way back to
to that period way before jesus was ever
around
the jews themselves were colonized
speaking of colonization
they were colonized by the romans they
were colonized by the byzantines they
were colonized by the crusaders by the
ottomans
and finally by the british and you know
just to
give people a little bit of historical
perspective what is palestine what is
that name
the romans renamed the region syria
palestina
after the philistines to kind of give a
middle finger to the jews that they had
pushed
out as a way of punishing the jews
because the philistines were their
mortal enemy
so it's like you know when israel
sort of miraculously and i think this is
what makes it such a hard story for
people to understand
most indigenous populations are screwed
over
they never get a chance to return to
their land but israel got that chance
after the holocaust
in 1948 1947 1948
and basically the u.n comes to the
jewish people
and says we are and and the arabs living
in the region
and says here is the partition plan
essentially the jews get half the
muslims get half and not the muslims the
jews get half the arabs get half
and the jews said great and their
motivation for saying great was they
weren't going to get anything else
and in totally real politic terms it
makes sense that the palestinians said
no
but then they said no again after every
single
offer to split the land and and i think
that that is really
what it's about in the end do jews have
any right to have any self-determination
in any piece
of their indigenous land or not and by
the way it's
not it's not to say that you know given
that
like little history that i just swept
you through the crusades and everything
else like is there a long-standing
palestinian connection to the land
and muslim connection to the land yes of
course there is is there a long-standing
christian connection
of course there is right the question is
only do we also acknowledge
that the jews have a connection to that
land or not and that to me is what
everything is about
is there room for an argument or a
debate where people say we completely
understand
israel's right to exist we support
israel's right to exist
but the expansive nature of a lot of the
policies
and maybe netanyahu himself as being
somebody who is uh you know has
certainly
uh put more of a right-wing face
on uh policies and the bulldozing of the
settlements
and evicting people from their homes is
there a space for people to
argue like listen we think israel should
exist
but you know as a as a expect
because when you say colonial power i
think part of what gives that argument
credence in people's minds is that the
borders of israel don't seem to be fixed
they constantly seem to keep expanding
and israel keeps evicting people from
their homes and
there there there is that that is
what most people regard as a colonial
um you know posturing from israel it's
not like
okay here are the borders and we're done
and i'm sure it's
you know there's some complexities there
but that's why p
like you said people are saying israel
is a colonial state
but it seems like they're that they're
not finished like the borders aren't
uh you know rock solid that they're
expanding and taking
more and more territory and some people
fear that they're taking
they want all the territory right so is
there a space to criticize bibi
netanyahu
100 i'll do it right now i did it often
in the pages of the new york times
is there a place to oppose settlements
and settlement expansion in the west
bank
of course i oppose them i do that all
the time what what this is about
again is fundamental existence and let
me just give you an example of that in
israel pulled out every single jew every
single israeli that lived in the gaza
strip every single one
left all of the infrastruct the hot
houses behind etc
what happens then it's not that there is
a
flourishing you know singapore uh on on
in the gaza strip could have been
possible tons of money flowed into gaza
instead what there is is a piece of land
in proxima and rocket proximity to the
center of israel
run by a group that says in its charter
that their goal is not two states that
their goal
is to exterminate every single jew this
is from their charter there is no
solution to the palestinian question
except through jihad the day of judgment
will not come about until the muslims
fight jews and kill them
then the jews will hide behind the rocks
and trees and the rocks and trees will
cry out oh muslim
there's a jew hiding behind me come and
kill them that's not just in the
founding it's also in these videos that
i pulled for you
that i don't think many people see so
maybe we want to play the one
about with the hamas senior official
talking about
we'll do that now and we'll we'll add
that in post
and then there's a second video where
the mother
of uh palestinian martyr as as they
would call him
talks about the jews and says may their
hearts be ripped out
may their eyes be gouged out
so that is what happened when israel
pulled out of the gaza strip
now you have the situation where israel
is occupying the west bank
and it's a horrible situation and i
oppose it the problem is is that
just from a purely like
existential perspective given what
happened when israel pulled out of the
gaza strip
there is an understandable fear and if
you want to understand why
so many israelis feel torn about this
their fear is okay what happens if we
pull out of the west bank
and there is another hamas terrorist
statelet at our other border
and the mid point of israel is like a
mile wide
that's an existential problem and so you
have a tension
where obviously continuing to occupy
another
people that you know like i believe
in a two-state solution i believe in the
palestinian right to self-determination
just as i believe in the jewish one
period but you have to understand
where that fear is coming from and why
israel doesn't just
unilaterally pull out of the west bank
as they did in gaza
you know 15 years ago right better help
better
atlp i'll tell you right now there's no
better place to get online counseling it
is fast
start communicating with a licensed
professional in under 48 hours
it's professional counseling done
securely online broad range of expertise
available which may not be locally
available in many areas the service is
available for clients worldwide
right now as quarantine's ending we're
all being thrust back into social
situations
we may be mentally unprepared for but
better help is committed to facilitating
great therapeutic matches
so they make it easy and free to change
counselors if you need it's more
affordable than traditional online
counseling and financial aid is
available better
help help want you to start living a
happier life today visit their website
read any of their testimonials
betterhelp.com timd
that's better help timd
join the over 1 million people who've
taken charge of their mental health with
the help of an experienced professional
in fact
so many people have been using better
health that they're recruiting
additional counselors
in all 50 states you got to get on the
train here folks
you'll feel much better you'll be able
to communicate more effectively i'm
telling you
it is great i use it all the time i call
in the morning what's going on
hey how you been better help who's am i
talking to is this
ross hey ross it's tim i feel sad and
then he goes
don't be sad and i go that's right
betterhellbetterhlp.com tim d
do it and do it now this podcast is
sponsored by better help and timbaland
show listeners get 10 off their first
month at betterhelp.com
tim d the penises are out you want them
to be hard you want them to be effective
it's the summer love everybody's happy
quarantine's over you're trying to get
out there meet that special person [ __ ]
around meet a bunch of different people
blue chew is unique online service it
delivers the same active ingredients
as viagra and cialis but in chewable
tablets at a fraction of the cost
you could take them any time day or
night or you can plan ahead and be ready
whenever an opportunity arises the
process is simple sign up at
bluetooth.com
consult with one of their licensed
medical providers and once you're
approved you'll recreate
you'll receive the prescription within
days the best part it's all done online
no visits to the doctor no awkward
conversations no waiting
in line at the pharmacy bluetooth
tablets are made in the usa and prepared
and shipped direct to your door in a
discrete package
blue chew is great i love blue chew you
don't even have to have sex sometimes
you just want to take them wake up look
at it and go back to bed
it's time to get off the couch and back
to work if your tool needs an upgrade
head to bluetooth.com
there's only one thing sexier than
confidence and that's
a big [ __ ] blue true can help give you
the confidence where it counts
so if you could benefit from extra
confidence when it's time to perform
bluetooth can help
and we've got a special deal for our
listeners try bluetooth free when you
use our promo code td at checkout how
crazy is that
you just pay five dollars shipping
bluetooth.com promo code td
first month free visit bluetooth.com for
more details
and important safety information we
thank bluechu for sponsoring
the podcast this episode is brought to
you by another podcast show i'm not
being ambiguous when i say that that's
the name of the podcast i'm recommending
another podcast show
you already know dylan rand patrick
hickey and producer of king and the
sting in this past week at nick davis
from when i raved about their hit show
another below deck podcast
well they're all back imagine that the
unkillable
uh the to ride the coattails of my
success for the duration of the final ad
read
after a dodge coin asked investment into
the tim dylan show in late 2019 they've
broken a ridge wallet deal right
great this time with a more general show
unconstrained by the shackles of reality
tv recaps to cover
the trending topics of our time like
native american shoe salesmen illuminati
recruiters living in rural jamaica
fighting the culinary union and escaping
las vegas so if you would like to
continue to support fake business
truly head over to apple podcast and
leave a review for another podcast show
and say that tim dillon sent you
do this guys or leave a youtube comment
on their latest episode saying the same
that's another podcast show on youtube
apple podcast and spotify
and listen if they weren't doing this
they'd be doing mass shootings so let
them do this
comment thank you why was
why was the plo like israel and the plo
had so many issues
it seemed like the plo was kind of this
secular
option right in terms of you know of the
different
factions of people that israel could
negotiate with why
were was israel kind of demonizing the
plo
is is there a hope again that
because when you say the other side is
hamas i don't know if hamas represents
all palestinians right oh no no let me
be extremely clear
the palestinians in gaza are living
under hamas occupation
understood but right but isn't it
because they can't
leave and it's not a functional state so
there's
nothing let me just finish that i want
to be like
super clear about in the same way that i
would make a distinction between the
chinese communist party
and the average chinese person right of
course i would make a distinction
between
you know dictatorial totalitarian
leaders
who throw gay people off buildings right
and
like and and actual people who live in
miserated lives because of them
and the average palestinian what do i
think they want i think they want a good
life
i think they want the exact same thing
that anyone else wants of course i think
is that yeah is my my question is like
who can israel negotiate
i mean now i guess it is hamas but how
can there be
any like there's a ceasefire now uh
netanyahu is out there's a new
government being formed now
is there a new yeah is there a new one
sorry i didn't mean to interrupt you
it's hard to like read you with the
glasses
i was gonna say there's this new
coalition government right with
with an arab party in the coalition
like this is a historic thing that's
just happened in israel for the first
time ever
this rama party i think it's called and
do you think is the hope
that there will be uh you know
something in the in the way of a
two-state solution being discussed
because
that seems the only possible
solution you have yes and i think
love trump or hit or hate trump the
reality is
did anyone 10 years ago ever think that
israel would sign a historic peace offer
with countries like
qatar and the uae and saudi arabia that
there would be flights from tel aviv to
abu dhabi like the world is changing the
region is changing
and i think what's happening
increasingly you know whatever you think
of those countries is that
israel is increasingly being accepted
like that it's not going away and that's
the key to peace
if the if palestinian leadership can
accept that
israel's just not going to go away it's
not going to
erase itself out of existence that's
where peace comes and i think
you see that and to me like that was an
enormously
huge seismic shift that happened in the
middle east the fact of this
new coalition government the fact that
you know like
20 and i'm not sure people understand
this 20
of israeli citizens are israeli arabs or
palestinians
like 22 of israel's mit the technion
is made up of israeli arabs they're in
knesset they win reality tv shows like
this is such a like there is just such a
gap
between reality and the kind of things
that you see from bella hadid's
instagram feed
about what's actually going on there and
frankly i would love to take you maybe
maybe abby martin would want to come too
um to to give people a sense of
what's really happening there because
like so many things in the legacy press
there's just an enormous gap between
reality and this kind of like
american parochial fantasy projection
and i'm sure that it is reality shows it
being won and there's it is all love and
light
but when you shell when you shell
the associated press building
i mean that's not a great thing right
can we agree with that
shelling anything is tragic
killing people right yes what do you of
course
right but it's it's especially that it's
a press building
and it seems like you have a country
trying to intimidate the press when they
do that
tim tim israel's had to shell hospitals
israel's had to shell schools why
because hamas's strategy is for innocent
people to get killed
i know that it's very hard for like
coddled american brains to understand
this
but like it is not hamas's goal
to protect its population right it's
hamas's goal to let its people
suffer and die that is why it launches
rockets
from literally inside hospitals and
kindergartens
right that's that's the reality and so
like what do you do
right if you are and israel has gone to
like insane degrees
to try and mitigate against innocent
people getting killed but it's
it's horrible and they're and it's like
you look at the stories of these
children and it's
it's it's horrible there's like there's
no
the full stop that's it but it's like we
have to look at
why they're in that situation right
well i mean it's it's it's tough i hope
that there's
some solution to it
um that you know upholds the dignity of
people i mean
when you see the way the people living
in palestine that's not
i think a sustainable thing and most
people i think
looking at this would say it's not
sustainable you know and right
yeah i i can i completely agree with you
that's why i support a two-state
solution
that's why i think that the sooner
palestinian leadership can accept
israel's existence the closer we'll get
to peace
why don't the christians go back i mean
didn't we i mean
isn't this time to start listening to
the christians my people
is it not time to start you ready for
another crusades
i am a little bit i mean don't we think
it's time now to realize
that the other religions have had a time
but the christians are kind of still the
we're the we're the ones you guys are
the kings well
i mean am i wrong that seems
i mean we've never done it the
christians we just behave we have dinner
i mean i think you need to go back to
your crusader history here's what i'll
say
the i mean this is again like one of
those stories that's enormous and that
no one has talked about
there has been a systemic purge of
christians
from the middle east over the past
several years yes coptic christians in
egypt yes i know that yes
there's like no christians left in the
middle east you know where there's
christians
in israel palestinian christians there's
no
christians in gaza like right like
so again like as imperfect as israel is
like i think people need to have a
little perspective when it's clearly a
more
tolerant society to live in that's a
fact
and where are people who are fleeing
gays fleeing persecution in the west
bank going for refuge they're going to
tel aviv they're going to israel
right so it kind of it's a little
sorry if i sound impassioned it boggles
my mind a little bit
to hear people who identify themselves
as progressives
and liberals sort of overlooking
like the immigration of muslim
minorities across the
of muslims across the world uyghurs in
china
500 000 palestinian ref palestinians who
live in refugee camps in lebanon
and who are not allowed certain jobs
they interviewed a palestinian guy two
days ago
palestinian born in kuwait built a
hummus empire in minneapolis amazing
story
why did he leave kuwait because he was a
palestinian he told me he's a third
class citizen
can't get into university went to
elementary school in the second half of
the day because he's palestinian
it's like somehow only when israel or
the jews are involved
do we care about the lives of muslims
and arabs and palestinians and i think
that that is something that deserves a
closer look
[Music]
clearly or and i'm not saying you're
saying it does
but i know that it it's been difficult
for them and yes they experienced
the arab world is rife with sectarian
conflicts where everyone hates each
other right i mean that's not
that's not new i just think that there's
got to be some
decision about where israel's borders
are and i think the constant expansive
nature of the policy
and the settlements in the west bank and
kind of what seems like it's a
a policy that's kind of based on
agitation
and that to the outside viewer to
somebody like me who's again
not a big stake in the game here i look
at that and i go
that when you see people getting evicted
from their homes
and i know that ben shapiro is saying
that it was you know
a bill coming due from years and years
ago or whatever it's a contract
the sheikh jura thing i tried to
understand i watched him three times it
was a
contract somebody getting back it just
does it seems
yeah yeah but but all you need to like
just make it super basic
yeah the shake the shake giraffe thing
yeah i don't support what israel was
doing but it was about six homes
watch those clips from hamas what's it
about i understand
but i think it's like when it's six
homes six
families six groups of people it just
blows up
think about america and how many
movements have been started about
you know one interaction with police
that's gone wrong
so even though it's six homes i think
that there's like you know
the power of media and the power of
everything it it
it's i think it exemplifies the issue to
people
i don't think yeah but but you're saying
the power of media you have to ask
yourself
why is there this obsession with this
conflict
why is there an obsession with this
conflict to the exclusion of
everything else well because it's so
long-standing
i know that you would say it's because
of anti-semitism it's a bed in china
no i'm just saying like it's not that
long-standing it's pretty long-standing
right it's about since i mean depending
on how you count but you could say it's
from 48 or 67.
in the scope of like ongoing wars in the
world
it's not that law i mean it's terrible
it's horrible i think it's the
occupation is
eating at the soul of israel's democracy
like i have no problem saying that
but you you have to wonder like why is
there this
absolute and utter fixation with this
tiny economy
america is very supportive of israel
right so you have
any conflict in the middle east you have
america getting drawn into it
on on in terms of narrative like america
has to make a decision america has been
incredibly supportive of israel
um you know when trump moves the embassy
to jerusalem it just becomes a massive
news story because it is america it's an
american president doing it
and yes there's anti-semitism out there
and people do fixate on things
because of anti-semitism but this seems
to be it's about the fact that america
is so
supportive of israel's actions
that i think it makes the story bigger
than it
might necessarily otherwise be
but it's like you're constantly hearing
about let's say american foreign aid
it's like america gives
tens of billions of dollars in foreign
aid to countries all over europe to
egypt all over the middle east and like
there's this obsession on israel the
reason to him that i'm
interested in that is like that
demonization that is so beyond criticism
has actual effects in the lives of jews
in this country of course
yeah like like when a caravan of people
waving palestinian flags
drives through west hollywood and pulls
up to a sushi restaurant and says
who's a jew and then beats the [ __ ] out
of people or where a caravan of cars
in the uh jewish neighborhood in london
drives through and says [ __ ] the jews
and rape their daughters like yes
that's why i'm that's why i care about
this so much right i don't
i care about this like israel's going to
do it israel's
its own country that's a foreign
conflict the reason it matters so much
to so many american jews beyond you know
the fact that for many reasons
is because the way people talk about
israel
has incredible ramifications on jews all
over the world
should it be constitutional though to
boycott israel if you want to
the bds movement like it seems to be
your free speech
person is it weird to mandate that
american citizens have
a responsibility to not boycott the
actions of a foreign country
like those i think what you're referring
to are these bills that
that say that there is
you know boycott divestment yeah yeah
but what the bills say
is that americans america that states
and governments won't do contracts with
businesses
that support bds just in the way that
america that
states have contracts that say we won't
do business
with companies that support you know a
white supremacist organization it's
like what is bds about it does a college
student have a right to stand up and say
boycott israel 100 does that be martin
have a right to go on youtube and say
that and should her
video be not be taken down 100 but like
let's be clear about what bds is bds is
a movement
not about palestinian rights not about
creating a palestinian state
not about opposing the israeli
occupation of the west bank
it's about the eradication of the state
of israel and the question is whether or
not you think that that policy itself
is anti-semitic in effect if not an
intent
well a hundred a hundred percent is is
anti-semitic if that's what the the
policy is
it is sure but shouldn't you be let's
say
somebody says hey i don't believe that
israel or the united states or whatever
country has the right to exist because
of the way it was founded
right do you stifle that person's right
to speak even though i think it's a
ridiculous thing do you stifle that
person's right to speak
and i my answer would be no my answer is
also no
what i think is important to add to it
though is
is what bds is about i i think people
really don't get it most people who are
supporting bds
like young people or you know that think
they're anti-zionist think they're just
supporting the underdog
no what bds is about is the elimination
of the largest jewish community
on planet earth that's it miami and
that's okay
the uh are they trying to they're
they're they're right now they're trying
to get rid of my happiness
i was gonna wear like a uh like a boca
lady outfit for you you should have well
listen
where can people support you and find
you now because i know you left the new
york times did you leave or did they get
you it was a thing right you just said
it's time for me to go
i i jerry mcguired myself out of there
right yeah
yeah was it weird to work there where
people people were
hostile to you openly towards the end
oh some people were hostile openly in
the beginning but yes
right okay yeah all right it wasn't
it was it was uh it was not the middle
east but it was a hostile
situation and you know like you talk
about a lot on your show
there's there's i think that the most
interesting independent voices right now
are
on the outside and not the inside of
these institutions and i wanted to leave
so that i could
be free to tell the truth which is the
reason i became a journalist to begin
with
right where can people support me yeah
they can support me at um
on my newsletter it's
barryweiss.substack.com
and i'm going to be launching a podcast
in a few days and i know that you're
going to be doing lunch that day
or in no we just would cancel you just
because we made a joke about you so we
said
barry west will definitely cancel the
podcast but the fact
that you haven't it's i'm we're shocked
you're shocked i mean i don't know i
don't hang out with journalists and i
don't know these people
yeah i just know that we make fun of
katie herzog all the time and katie
always comes on
we do like katie herzog a lot well katie
herzog uh has
an amazing series going on right now on
my newsletter
about um the spread of the illiberal
ideology
in the world of medicine and there's an
absolutely bananas
up there today it's not good it's not
good
people should read it and uh no i'm a
huge fan i mean as you know my favorite
even though you go after me and various
other people
uh i freaking loved
the segment on the airbnb lesbians which
i have watched
several times they i'm still banned and
you know it's uh you want to talk about
israel-palestine this is another
long-standing conflict of which there
will be no two-state solution
and i feel like i'm the
the people that are you i don't know i
mean i i feel like
they have they feel like i have the
power and they feel like
and they i feel like they have the power
so
nobody really i just i was thrown off
airbnb
i literally you actually were banned for
me i'm banned we have to use ben's
account i stay in hotels
most of the time anyway but like you
know it's it's crazy and it's not even a
deep platforming discussion you can
enter into
because nobody has any sympathy when
you're thrown off airbnb it's not like
you would throw off twitter
or anything people are just like they
think you're like unsanitary or
something and
and again lesbians shouldn't be
decorating homes this is the reality
in the same way that gay men shouldn't
be doing certain things and it's a
natural conflict between gays and
lesbians but
you know maybe they will they'll come on
and we'll we'll talk it out with them i
don't know if you know them they're very
stylish
i i would love to broker that camp david
accord
on this show as as someone that you know
identifies with parts of who they are
parts of who you are i feel like i can
be
switzerland in that situation well we
hope well we thank you again barry i
know the week was tough
barry weiss.substack.com
uh you can subscribe to barry's
newsletter that's out there and support
what she's doing
and we appreciate for coming on and now
no one can get angry
because we've had everybody on uh except
the
real winners the christians who should
be giving the whole area back
because we're the people who've never
done anything to anyone
that's the truth that's the truth
christians have become the people to
really
be to rely on in my in my uh we have
like a nice we have like a whole
it's too much with the jews and the
arabs all the time bring the christians
in let's do the easter
it's nice for everyone barry weiss thank
you
thank you very much we appreciate it